[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans le grand
jt des territoires sur tv5monde et sur
vos chaînes locales et régionales voici
tout de suite les titres de l'actualité
de cette édition vous le savez lundi
dernier entre et en vigueur le pass
vaccinale permettant l'accès à certains
lieux publics une décision qui est loin
de plaire à tout le monde vous verrez
dans ce journal ce reportage dans le
nord avec nos confrères de wéo la chaîne
de la voix du nord
dans ce journal le procès le plus
attendu de l'année celui de north dan le
landais les équipes de télé grenoble
nous feront découvrir le lieu du procès
dans un instant non ce journal la
rencontre avec un philosophe il savait
tôt mme benoît il sort un livre qui
s'appelle aphorismes sur l' architecture
l'occasion de parler avec lui de sa
vision de l'urbanisme dans les
territoires et du développement de sa
ville natale marseille et puis on
terminera ce grand journal des
territoires par la consécration d'un
châtaignier des yvelines il s'est vu
décerner le prix d'arbres de l'année un
titre que cette arme tricentenaire n'a
pas volé les terres
nous ouvrons ce journal avec le pass
vaccinale qui prouve que le détenteur a
eu un schéma vaccinal complet il est
entré en vigueur vous le savez ce lundi
et il ne fait évidemment pas l'unanimité
comme a pu le constater dans les hauts
de france caroline fichten de wéo la
chaîne de la voix du nord
c'est un geste dont on a désormais
l'habitude le scan du qr codes à
l'entrée des restaurants sauf qu'à
partir de ce lundi c'est le pass
vaccinale que les clients doivent
présenter et tous n'y sont pas
favorables
moi je suis contre parce que je trouve
que c'était bien que les gens vaccinés
puis se sont toutes façons sont vaccinés
c'est bien et que le ceux qui n'étaient
pas vaccinés se faisait testé à la
limite c'était plus sur quoi qu'il se
passe je veux pas d'activer leurs
angoisses en sortait
que c'est pas une contrainte en fait on
s'en moque et
il faut le faire il faut le faire de
toute façon c'est important c'est la
santé tous quoi à bien comme partout
ailleurs les avis sont partagés ce pass
vaccinale est parfois perçue comme une
privation de liberté une manière
déguisée de forcer les gens à se faire
vacciner on aurait dû plutôt essayer de
persuader les gens plutôt que de les
forcer parce que le côté fort c'est
comme ça ça suppose une privation de
liberté ça c'est c'est presque
intolérable pour un citoyen je pense que
c'est une bonne chose mais
temporairement parce que effectivement
ça va peut être enfin c'est
discriminatoire avait quelque part et du
coup c'est pas quelque chose qui doit
rester dans le temps autres lieux
concernés par la mise en application du
pass vaccinale les salles de sport ici
pas de grands changements par rapport à
avant ce qui fait du tort à l'activité
comme dans certains restaurants
d'ailleurs c'est le recours accru au
télétravail on a clairement vu quand
même eu une influence réduite aussi bien
en salle de sport que sur les cours
collectifs notamment le midi les gens
télétravail ça ça nous pose énormément
de soucis
les cours qu'on avait le midi où des
gens venaient là le télétravail nous
fait beaucoup de tort nous on travaille
beaucoup avec les salariés le midi mais
avec le travail ça fait vraiment du
temps pour notre entreprise mais c'est
vrai qu'on a plus des personnes
retraitées maintenant que les gens qui
travaillent
un problème qui se résoudra peut être
prochainement avec un assouplissement
des règles de télétravail à partir du 2
février
voilà ce pass vaccinale est entrée en
vigueur une fois qu'il a été validée par
le conseil constitutionnel
une institution présidée par laurent
fabius qui était l'invité jeudi dernier
de l'émission face aux territoires sur
tv5 monde et dans laquelle il a insisté
sur le rôle important des territoires
écoutons le
je crois beaucoup
c'est le sens de votre question à la
force des territoires mai
je ne serais pas étonné si dans le futur
et il y à une nouvelle phase de
décentralisation mais évidemment ça
appartient aux autorités politiques
responsables pourquoi pour donner plus
de pouvoir aux territoires pour donner
plus de marge de manoeuvre plus de
possibilité de décider parce que je
crois qu un des paradoxes de la
situation aujourd'hui c'est que la fois
les phénomènes sont de plus en plus
interconnecté que ce soit au niveau
national au niveau mondial et en même
temps qu'on a besoin d'autonomie et
d'initiative
et c'est vrai que les initiatives sont
souvent prises par au niveau local c'est
vrai pour les régions départements ou
vous les communes bien évidemment la
france doit être unités mais je crois à
cette dynamique locale et on voit que
lui-même beaucoup d'initiatives être
prises dans les différentes régions
voilà dans ce journal je vous propose
d'entendre maintenant le cri d'alarmé de
philippe tribunaux cet homme souffre
d'une électrosensibilité il est obligé
de vivre loin de toute pollution
électrique et ce n'est pas si simple
dans notre monde actuel vous l'imaginez
il s'est donc installé dans une caravane
sur un terrain communal est lui qui dit
aspirer à une vie confortable se
considère maintenant comme un sdf
regardez le devant la caméra de eric
kamwa du journal la provence nos
correspondants sur place ils en
appellent aux pouvoirs publics
là il ya une antenne qui construire
trois kilomètres d'ici cas de grandes
chances intactes et mon campement contre
laquelle je me bats est par contre je
demande simplement ce que l'état me
trouve un autre lieu de vie de lundi au
moi je suis pas capable de le trouver
seul j'en ai pas les moyens j'en ai
énergie et jupe quand je sors au maximum
dans un rayon de 1 km d'ici veuve d'un
kilomètre d'une heure là en voiture
d'ici donc j'ai pas les moyens de
trouver un autre lieu de vie donc ils
demandent à l'état de faire un moratoire
le temps que avec ses services on trouve
une solution pour reloger ailleurs
voilà ce sujet de nos confrères de la
provence nous restons à marseille à 130
km de la direction le sud nous nous
retrouvons comme je vous le disais dans
les titres tom benoît philosophe
essayiste spécialiste de la cité
phocéenne au moment où l'on parle de
ville et d'architecturé dans les
territoires alors selon vous tom benoît
bonjour aujourd'hui quels sont les
enjeux majeurs en matière d'urbanisme
on peut diviser les enjeux majeurs à
marseille en deux segments en matière
d'urbanisme d'une part la transition
écologique et d'autre part la quête
identitaire alors pourquoi la transition
écologique tout simplement parce qu'il
s'agit là d'une main tendue par la météo
sociétale de l'époque pour nous à
marseille on a un environnement qui
n'est pas encore saturé par la pollution
et ça c'est une acception la plupart des
grandes métropoles de france sont
saturés par la pollution et vont entamer
les le prélude de la transition
écologique dans une démarche de
sauvetage et pas dans une démarche
constructive la deuxième kate et c'est
une quête identitaire en matière
d'urbanisme parce qu'il faut réellement
que au dessus de toutes démarches
urbanistiques qui plane une dimension
identitaire dans marseille pour apporter
d'identité au territoire que ce soit là
aussi par le commerce l'entrepreneuriat
ou leur filature en elle même la
conception architecturale
alors justement vous évoquez l'identité
que ce soit à marseille dans d'autres
villes comment envisager une politique
urbaine qui permettent d'apporter cette
identité au territoire
ona en france à l'heure actuelle 70 % de
la population qui est éligible au
logement sociaux or c'est là où il ya
une dimension politique dans cette
problématique des logements sociaux que
nous n'avons pas d'ailleurs que nous
n'avons pas terminé de construire et qui
ne sont pas disponibles sur le parc
immobilier dont il faut avoir de plus en
plus entrepreneur de manager deux
commerçants mais pas de plus en plus de
personnes qui soient éligibles selon
sociaux alors vous êtes un philosophe un
peu particulier vous exercez une
activité de consultant auprès des
agences d'architecturé alors en quoi
cela consiste de quelle façon vous
tentez de faire évoluer la situation où
se situe en fait les marges de manoeuvre
des architectes dans la conception de la
ville de demain d'une part vous avez
l'affectation qu'ils aient pensé par
celles et ceux qui conçoivent la cité et
d'autre part vous avez l'usv l'usl qui
est constituée justement de la
quotidienneté des habitants de celles et
ceux qui habitent les lieux et à force
de loger les gens les gens ne savent
plus habiter les lieux donc c'est donc
cette dimension qui a l'aspect
analytique et qu'il faut réellement
analyser la territorialité et moi ce que
je propose dans mon activité ce sont des
bilans dans lesquels je présente toute
la dimension
qui gravitent autour d'un projet de
l'implantation de celui ci dans une
sociologie territoriales dernière
question tout benoît je sais que vous
êtes un sportif un boxeur même alors à
propos de la volonté de renaud muselier
le président de la région sud de
présenter la candidature de votre région
aux jeux olympiques d'hiver pour 2034 ou
2038 est-ce que vous pensez que c'est
une bonne idée qu il s'y prend bien
je pense que l'investissement de près de
200 millions je crois dans le le ski
d'ici à 2034 2038 représente une
plus-value pour un sport bien
particulier pour un périmètre bien
particulier de la région mais là aussi
qui représente pas spécialement le
caractère sportif et identitaire de la
région paca est pas réellement le sport
en général sur la région paca voilà
pourquoi je n'aurais pas ses choix ce
n'est pas dramatique pour autant mais je
n'aurais pas fait le même choix chrono
muselier merci tome benoît vous étiez en
direct de marseille et je rappelle vous
êtes l'auteur du livre instinct
mimétique et solitude a servi préfacé
par rudy riciotti mais en furie merci à
vous
sans transition je vous le disais dans
les titres le 31 janvier s'ouvre pour
trois semaines le procès de norman le
landais accusé de l'enlèvement et de
l'assassinât de la petite maï enis alors
âgé de 8 ans
luna d'un vivier de télégrenoble a pu
visiter le lieu où se tiendra le procès
le plus attendu de ce début d'année on
part pour grenoble
c'est ici que sera jugée nordahl le
landais à compter du 31 janvier prochain
c'est ici dans cette salle que tout va
se jouer pour l'homme accusé de
l'enlèvement et du meurtre de maylis de
araujo un procès hors normes qui s'étale
sur trois semaines et pour lequel la
cour d'appel de grenoble se prépare
depuis un an et demi l'accusé sera
présent dans ce box qui est sécurisé
vous aurez donc de sur sa sur sa droite
vous aurez ici le greffier de qui sera
chargé de prendre en charge dans tout
l'est tous les actes d'audience la
partie principale qui sera composée du
jury avec la présidente et les jurés qui
seront installés sur cette partie là
pour cette affaire le palais de justice
a demandé une rallonge budgétaire de 194
milles euros notamment pour installer
une retransmission des débats dans une
deuxième salle d'audience
capable d'accueillir 60 autres personnes
dans la salle de retransmission
les journalistes ou les personnes
période présentes pourront voir tous les
acteurs du procès enfin tous les acteurs
principaux du procès donc ça donnera
finalement aux personnes présentes dans
la salle de retransmission
presque finalement la même qualité que
s'ils étaient présents dans la salle
d'assises alors qu'au moins 200
journalistes sont attendus pour couvrir
l'événement le palais s'engage à
protéger les parties civiles elles
porteront des cordons de couleurs
différentes
signalant leur volonté ou non de
s'exprimer face à la presse les jurés
pourront eux aussi bénéficier d'un
service spécial il est laurent n'a mis
en place aussi je le précise parce que
ça c'est quelque chose d'un peu plus
exceptionnel
une assistance psychologique aux jurés
puisque on sait très bien que ces procès
d'assises et particulièrement celui là
sera riche en émotions très très
intenses donc ça peut être très
difficile à vivre pour des jurés qui
n'ont par hypothèse pas l'habitude de
siéger en cour d'assises la sécurité
sera quant à elle renforcer
à l'intérieur les identités seront
contrôlés dehors la circulation et le
stationnement seront limitées en somme
beaucoup d'aménagements pour un des plus
grands procès de l'année 2022 et de
grenoble
voilà sans transition à la proche de la
réouverture des boîtes de nuit en
février les acteurs du secteur demandent
à revoir le statut de leur établissement
ils ont été privés de clients pendant 19
mois depuis mars 2020 explications
d'alain drouot de 7 à limoges en
nouvelles aquitaine
avec une date de reprise fixée au 16
février les exploitants de discothèques
se remettent tandis ouverture ne sera
pas assujettis à des comptes pour
l'instant à des contraintes sanitaires
strictes puisqu'on avait déjà dit qu'il
n'y avait une ligne rouge à ne pas
franchir c'était le fait qu' on vienne
avec le pass vaccinale ok mais surtout
pas ce test pcr de moins de 24 heures et
les jeunes nous avait dit écoutez on a
servi vous avez servi de cobayes vous
les discothèques pour ce qu'on se fasse
vacciner on s'est tous fait vacciner
maintenant la troisième dose on va la
faire mais si à chaque fois qu'on vient
chez vous on doit faire un test pcr vous
ne nous reverrait pas au delà de la
reprise les propriétaires pose la
question des statuts de leur entreprise
pendant la fermeture des établissements
de nuit avec musique sont restés ouverts
nous avons tous les critères qui sont
déjà prêts déterminer si on veut et on
peut trouver une solution un modus
vivendi entre la discothèque et ce qui
n'est pas discothèque législation
française est pleine de trous dans
laquelle vont vont s'engouffrer tous
ceux qui veulent bien un petit peu quoi
et on se trouve et nous fermer
discothèque alors que certains de nos
collègues qui font le même métier que
nos était ouvert au vu et au su de tout
le monde et en zone rurale même constat
que le problème est le même que toutes
les discothèques de france peuvent
rencontrer avec ces fermetures
fermetures ouvertures ouverture
fermeture
donc on sait pas trop sur quel pied
danser à la préfecture de la
haute-vienne les hommes de la nuit ont
été reçus avec attention sollicité pour
s'exprimer la préfète du département n'a
pas donné suite à notre demande
par là puis nous partons visite au
centre spatial de toulouse maintenant
dans ce grand jt des territoires où
thomas pesquet a répondu aux questions
de clément gaci du groupe la dépêche
notre partenaire
et vous allez voir le célèbre astronaute
a le même objectif qu'un certain tintin
regarder
la lune c'est alors quand je dis c'est
oui c'est notre objectif de massa au
pluriel parce que c'est au sein d'
agence spatiale européenne et avec le
rôle que joue la france évidemment en
tant que leader sur ses thématiques là
au niveau européen nos partenaires
américains tout le monde se met d'accord
en fait pour une fois ce n'est pas si
facile que tout le monde pousse dans le
même sens mais on sait que alors à terme
on veut aller sur mars on a des
questions fondamentales auxquelles on va
répondre sur mars mais là l'étape
nécessaire c'est la lune et comme je
disais tout à l'heure c'est bientôt
c'est aujourd'hui un vol avant la fin de
l'année un vol non habitées et les
chances de 12 ans avoir habité autour de
la lune et puis ensuite la surface et ça
va aller très très vite
voilà nous ouvrons une page écologie
dans ce journal aix-les-bains quimper 3
de nombreuses villes en france ont
adopté la collecte des déchets
recyclables à cheval anthony python de
lmtv s'est rendu sur place aux mains
ville à voir également adopté cette
méthode aussi insolite qu'écologique il
a fait la connaissance de nous pète un
robuste percheron regardez ce reportage
c'est drôle de bruit dans les rues du
vieux mans c'est celui de doublettes de
lui c'est une jument percheronne de 9
ans qui débute sa tournée dôme adhère
depuis le début d'année elle vient ici
chaque mardi matin collecter les déchets
recyclables
il faut des chevaux qu'il soit quand
même endurant parce que la tournée fait
enfin il ya quand même le travail il
faut pas oublier que c'est un vrai
travail donc il faut que de l'endurance
et puis beaucoup de calme et de sang
froid voilà il faut que la jument soit
capable d'attendre en tout en toutes
situations qu'ils restent calmes et
posées et qu'elle est qu'elle ait
confiance en nous et également dans ce
quartier aux ruelles étroites l'accès
est difficile pour les camions bennes
classique l'ipo mobile elle se fraye
bien plus facilement un chemin dans ce
quartier historique c'est c'est super en
tout cas ça fait du bien de voir un
animal dans les rues du vieux mans ça
fait moins de pollution déjà ça évite
les camions de venir paraissait
c'est sympa quoi du côté de la
municipalité à la démarche se veut avant
tout éco responsable et incitative bien
rapport de l'animal branchement avec les
gens qui aiment qui apporte le plus et
qui incite plus encore à faire trier
comme ça et à ramasser les les le tri
sélectif la tournée est prévue pour
durer deux heures mais en fait c'est
bien plus est- il doit s'arrêter souvent
pour répondre à toutes les attentions
que suscite du pet la semaine dernière
par exemple il ya un monsieur qui avait
ouvert par un couple entre les deux
familles qui avaient laissé une carotte
sur le sac pour la jument dure ça fait
plaisir voilà et puis les gens ils
remercient la juve or en passant ils lui
disent bonjour le cheval fait un est un
vrai lien social
il faudra s'habituer au bruit des
chevaux au mans la mairie étudie déjà à
l'extension de ce mode de collecte à
d'autres quartiers du centre ville
voilà dans ce journal nous vous parlons
régulièrement du phénomène qui touche
les côtes françaises celui de l'érosion
sur le bassin d'arcachon nous nous
rendons maintenant on se sert vous allez
le voir deux malheureux sapin de noël
pour essayer de la contrer tout le monde
est mis à contribution comme nous à les
voir dans ce reportage signé franck
poireau de télé7 la chaîne du groupe sud
ouest
plage de la salie inor à la teste les
enfants du conseil municipal des jeunes
des places les sapins de noël sur le
sable de la lune et les places les uns à
côté des autres le pied vers l'océan la
tête vers la lune le sam dati va venir
fallait tempête qui va se coincer dans
les dames et ça va faire remonter fallu
enfin pour la troisième année
consécutive l'office national des forêts
la ville de la teste un celle des sapins
de noël pour lutter contre l'érosion des
dunes système de brison plantation
d'oyats ses grands airs que l'on trouve
sur les dunes de sable du littoral
atlantique ces sapins de noël viennent
compléter d'autres dispositifs existants
pour retenir le sable ces arbres
recouvert de sable par exemple ont été
posées ici l'an dernier il est quand
même assez efficace et quand même et
c'est efficace après chaque support va
va avoir une utilité donc là le sapin il
va stocker dans un premier temps plus
tôt devant et après sur la partie
arrière un brise vent type ganivelles va
plutôt stockées sur la partie arrière
dans un premier temps donc qui vont à
chacun avoir un petit peu leur
spécificité mais le sapin est très très
efficace ces sapins lutte contre
l'érosion éolienne n'est pas l'érosion
marine qui creuse des falaises lorsque
la météo tourne à la tempête en revanche
en captant le sable ces arbres peuvent
aider à rattraper le profil des dunes
leur redonnait un profil plus
aérodynamique pour mieux résister aux
assauts de la nature puisque l'objectif
c'est que ce sable se stabilise ici et
ne passent pas derrière la dune et qui
est à ma gauche sans quoi ça étouffe les
plantes et plus particulièrement les
oyats donc c'est très efficace ce que
nous faisons là leur vernis à la commune
de la teste avait posé 19 ben de sapins
sur les dunes de la plage de la salie
nord cette année trente cinq bennes ont
été récupérés les sapins qu'elles
contiennent posé sur le sable de leur
permettent de fixer 1,2 km linéaires de
lune en moyenne sur cette plage
testerine le recul du trait de côte
oscillant fonction des années la météo
entre 4,3 et 15,2 m par an
voilà après le sapin un autre arbre dans
ce journal et pas n'importe lequel
puisqu'il s'agit d'un châtaignier de la
celle saint cloud dans les yvelines qui
s'est vu décerné par l'office national
des forêts le titre d'arbres de l'année
2021 l'équipe de tv 78 tu nous emmènes
rencontrer la star des arbres né sous le
règne de louis xiv tout de même regarder
il est grand et majestueux et à ses
propres fans la star du jour c'est ce
châtaignier de la celle saint cloud fier
de ses 18 mètres d'envergure il pose
devant les appareils photos des îles
noah venus en grand nombre pour le voir
la raison il vient de remporter le titre
de l'arbre de l'année je les ai vus dans
les magazines mais je me suis dit je
vais le prendre en photo ma mère se
châtaignier fait partie d'une
présentation qui a été faite sous louis
xiv y avait 350 châtaignier dans ce
quartier c'est le seul survivant il
était exploité pour deux choses d'une
part pour les châtaignes faisait la
farine de châtaigne pour se nourrir et
par ailleurs comme il y avait des vignes
sur les coteaux de la région parisienne
et dans ce quartier en particulier on
était régulièrement là pour faire les
échalas qui sont les piquer support des
17 de vigne un arbre qui surprend les
curieux visiteurs par son physique il
fait quand même quatre notes de l'argile
est énorme et il a une très grande
envergure et il est bon et je reviendrai
voir avec des feuilles les branches sont
sont très harmonieuse et puis le trou il
est quand même spécial et lévriers et
puis là trois cent cinquante ans ce chat
théniers âgée de trois cent trente ans
est situé dans un quartier résidentiel
au nom tout trouvé la châtaigneraie il
n'y a pas que moi qui suis fier
l'ensemble de la vie des fiers les gens
du quartier tout particulièrement
puisque c'est le symbole de leur
association une association de quartier
très très vivante qui connaît bien cet
art qui le surveillent attentivement en
espérant qu'ils tombent pas malades que
16 ans et branches seront pas cassé il a
330 en châtaignier ça peut vivre milan
donc sa prochaine étape c'est de doubler
le nombre d'années qu'il ya des chariots
et ce n'est pas fini pour lui il
représentera la france au concours de
l'arbre de l'année européen en 2022
voilà comme vous le savez peut-être la
bonne vieille chaudière au fuel sera
interdite dans notre pays le 1er juillet
prochain alors comment remplacer le
précieux combustible
réponse avec jean colonna et clara
marley de télé pas aisé encore ce qu'ils
ont rencontrées pour nous à fabricant de
granulés bois regarder le granulé bois
et le bois en général sont les énergies
les moins chers en corse et de partout
ailleurs et donc ce qui est fière
pouvaient être un frein c'est à dire
justement l'absence de granulés elles
pouvaient être un frein pour
l'investissement rapport
l'équipement de systèmes de chauffage à
nouveau aujourd'hui ça ne l'est plus
puisqu'il ya une usine qui qui en
fabrique le choix il est pertinent parce
que l'économie comment on est sûr sur
des choses qui coûtent de très peu chers
dont 15 kg de granulés qui correspondent
à peu près à une à une journée et demie
de chauffe pour un poil
ça coûte ça coûte 3 euros 90 donc c'est
à dire très peu voilà et puis pour tous
ceux qui passent leur nuit sur les jeux
vidéo sachez que la filière recrute
alors pour accompagner son développement
fulgurant la région auvergne rhône-alpes
à débloquer une aide de plus de cinq
cent mille euros pour ce secteur un
soutien bien utiles comme la vue manon
roche de tl7 la chaîne de la loire qui
s'est invité dans un studio de je
regardais un milliard de chiffre
d'affaires par an c'est ce que le jeu
vidéo rapporte dans la région à partir
du mois de mars 516 milles 382 euros
seront distribués aux sociétés
adhérentes aux organismes de locaux ou
de l'afdas une aide qui fait du bien aux
entreprises comme ce studio stéphanois
qui cherche à recruter pour finir de
développer son jeu vidéo l'objectif
c'est de de faire des formations
évidemment de
d'aider nos prochains nos futurs
recrutements avec leur formation surtout
qu'on a des grosses contraintes sur
notre projet actuel des contraintes art
graphique artistique et aussi sur les
les interfaces l'interface du jeu on a
un développeur un très bon développeur
mais on aurait besoin d'un soutien
évidemment et donc 2 2 personnes dans la
partie un peu plus graphique le but
étant de mieux former les salariés et
d'améliorer le recrutement le marché
sera donc plus développés mais est-ce
que ça va vraiment aider les petites
entreprises il faut savoir dans dans cet
univers vous avez des grands studios
type ubisoft conte à villeurbanne où
annecy et vous avez aussi des petits
studios qui sont en pleine croissance et
il suffit que vous ayez un jeu sur une
plate forme et tout de suite votre jeu
il peut être téléchargé par une personne
comme par des millions et donc un petit
studio peut s'adresser tout de suite à
un marché mondial est tout de suite car
tenez la région auvergne rhône alpes
souhaite alors devenir une grande région
du jeu vidéo en europe d'ici quelques
années
voilà et puis sachez que les musées
français se mettre de plus en plus à
organiser des prix littéraires ainsi à
paris le musée guimet a décidé d'un prix
de la littérature asiatique il est
décerné à l'auteur le japonais ce
mitsuyo kakuta pour son roman l'udm de
papier sont électrices française et
mâcha né de chez actes sud de ne manque
pas de mots pour nous donner envie de le
lire écouter plutôt ce livre l'une de
papier est un livre extrêmement efficace
dans sa virtuosité romanesque
est à la fois dans la profondeur des
sujets que met en place l'auteur de
livre en livre et se juger c'est c'est
la femme c'est la place de la femme dans
une société contemporaine asiatiques
mais qui peut être toutes les sociétés
de façon totalement universel
voilà j'ai pu pour finir ce journal et
pour rêver un peu vous découvrez sur des
images d'hervé zorgniotti de monaco info
quelques-uns des 177 lot de montres mise
en vente aux enchères par antiquorum 1
monaco le 18 janvier dernier une vente
prestigieuse qui a rapporté plus de 6,4
millions d'euros elles sont vraiment
magnifiques voilà merci d'avoir suivi le
grand jt des territoires sur tv5 monde
et vos chaînes régionales et locales de
la tnt on se retrouve très vite pour une
prochaine édition au revoir à tous
[Musique]